dans cet atelier qui ressemble un peu à
la caverne d'ali baba
jean-claude bouvier confectionne des
jouets en bois depuis 25 ans une passion
d'enfance qu'il a pu concrétiser après
un licenciement économique d'une
entreprise industrielle qui l'employait
comme mac est dit alors là ça c'est un
joueur et chaque donc les pièces je les
retourne je l'étais en moi même
ils sont entièrement tournés j'ai un
petit tour à voir enfin j'ai deux tours
à voir j'en ai un qui me sert pour pour
tourner des petites pièces et j'en ai un
autre plus gros pour tourner des pièces
légèrement plus drôle quoi ça c'est un
autre un autre genre de jeu d'échecs qui
sur pied avec son tiroir donc les mêmes
pièces de danse qui vont dedans donc ils
sont toutes tournées torreilles à la
main une par une
donc moi je vais tourner à l'oeil et
puis avec mon avec un k coulisses en jeu
je fais le jeu de petits chevaux
donc là les jeux de petits chevaux
on a un petit tireurs de chaque côté
donc les petits choux qui sont tous tous
endroits donc là il est temps le plateau
et en être hélas tous les motifs sont
pas tous qui est là c'est pas la main
donc je fais ça le week-end le soir ou
le matin de bonne heure des fois je me
lève à 5 heures du matin où je peins des
parents il avait pas dit l'ipad moyen
des jouets des icpe
alors comme les paons il allait il avait
tout le temps faire du bois dans les
forêts où couper des arbres tout ça
alors je prenais toujours débout et des
morceaux de bois puis fabriquer des
jouets mais les fabriques et moi même
alors moi le bois je vais le chercher
ici sur place
le plus loin c'est nogent le rotrou à
orleix être par contre sa gelée dans une
scierie parce qu'il vient de la forêt
d'orléans
non sinon le reste le noyer le poirier
le premier tout ça c'est que les voies
du point de vue souvent c'est des
clients qui me ramenait ça que je
contactais que votre il est alors
demandé s'il n'avait pas un angle celle
qui voulait qu'il ne voulait plus un
pommier poirier un homme heureux d'y est
ici c'est tout le stock de bois que
j'utilise pour pour fermer jouer les
maquettes quoi et tout ça c'est du bois
que des clients m'ont fourni qui étaient
étaient destinés pour mettre la cheminée
donc moi je le récupère je le coup et je
le fais sécher
il a dans j'en ai qui les y ont fait
état depuis une dizaine d'années quoi
donc là dedans je dus me rozier ça c'est
du poirier
non ça c'est du frêne bon à prendre ça
on va faire faire une petite voiture là
dedans petite voiture de sport
[Musique]
comme ça et on découpe au roman et
ensuite je suis les finitions à pomper
dans la marche pour fabriquer la plupart
de ses jouets jean-claude bouvier part
toujours d'un modèle réel qu'il
photographie et dont il réalise une
maquette ou 1 24e ce camion par exemple
lui a pris une centaine d'heures de
travail
moi je suis il me reste le gros lot à m
l'insulté vent là je fais une petite
tablette pour mettre le gps ou qui se
perdent pas et puis la bombe à la petite
porte sur le côté colle avec le le petit
banc les petits meubles de rangement qui
vont le dans un ballet début ça a été
plus facile pour trouver du client mais
avec un peu de persévérance et tous
après bon ben j'ai été démarché un petit
peu partout quoi et puis on pas
l'enseignante elle émule un petit peu
tout seul comme ça quoi du bouche à
oreille surtout donc ça c'est un ancien
s'est laissé l'ancien camion de pompiers
qu'ils amis ici à roue mais qu'ils
avaient aussi la caserne de deux lièvres
donc j'ai appelé la caserne et puis ceux
des radis saoudien mais ils m'ont dit tu
viens tout de suite et puis je vais fait
la maquette avec un stock de plusieurs
centaines de jouets jean-claude bouvier
m retient créer un musée du jouet en
bois artisanale ouvert
à d'autres artisans d'art